un travail exigeant qui porte finalement
ses fruits arborescence à Loches vient
de décrocher sa première étoile au guide
Michelin ou vers depuis à peine 3 ans
par Clément Dumont et sa compagne Océane
Guillot c'est une belle récompense pour
toutes l'équipe du restaurant c'est la
complicement d'un travail voilà de tous
les jours d'une exigence aussi et aussi
très heureux de ramener cette étoile à
Loches ça met en lumière un peu aussi
nos producteurs notre terroir une
annonce passe en conséquence car depuis
lundi les réservations s'enchaînent
dans la cuisine les produits sont avant
tout locaux 80% des producteurs
d'arborescence se situent dans un rayon
de 40 km autour du restaurant
à la casserole et après là je viens de
les mettre 12 heures dans un gastro à
couvert d'une entrée
de A à Z qui va nous demander trois
jours parce qu'on va chercher vraiment
les goûts les concentrations des
cuissons longues des recettes végétales
et florales tout en gardant une
gourmandise à la française voilà ce qui
définit la cuisine du chef fraîchement
étoilé après avoir fait ses armes dans
des cuisines du monde entier le couple
décide de s'installer sur sa terre
natale en Touraine on s'est pris de
charme par la ville et c'était pour nous
voilà c'était une évidence fallait qu'on
ouvre un restaurant ici aujourd'hui ça
nous montre l'étoile qu'on est sur le
droit chemin que notre cuisiner était
mise en lumière le restaurant était mise
en lumière à nous de d'avancer encore
plus
arborescence
ping
le du Juin 5 autres restaurants étoilé
en Indre-et-Loire inscrit au guide
Michelin 2023